[Applause]
here's the truth though donny t
if you don't send into new york i'll
take my [ __ ] car and drive to new
jersey
and i'll just get it in jersey he acted
like we ain't right there
yeah i'm in jersey it's right there yeah
give me an hour to drive in
with traffic i'll get yeah i'll go to
jersey i'll go to pa
i'll get it because yeah donnie t you're
gonna give it to new york we have to
close
we got to close these gates out can you
imagine new jersey started closing the
borders
how case would you be if the border if
you were on the wrong side of the board
of war for once here's the thing about
new jersey though if they decide to do
that everybody would have a guy that
could get you through the border because
new jersey are [ __ ] greasy
that's true if you just got cash cuz if
you got cash you could do anything in
jersey yeah there's no way they could
shut down the verrazano we'll get to
the verrazano's yeah from bay ridge you
could [ __ ] swim you could swim like
staten island
which is basically the way you get to
jersey yeah because yeah yeah it's what
it is i mean i think
i think that there's no way that it's
going to happen i do
think see here's the thing though too
here's what it is we're down the middle
guys it's like i think cuomo's as big of
an idiot as trump i think they're both
equally disturbingly bad for our country
just in different ways what a chromos i
mean peddling a book
in the middle of a pandemic where he
where his choices
killed thousands of elderly people
here's the difference though between him
and trump yeah
i mean he's more of a politician about
it but he's still gross but let's be
honest here's the difference trump's a
wasp
right so trump could do a lot of things
i hate and if trump invited me over for
dinner he's not going to change my mind
about me not liking him cuomo i could
hate the guy
if he invites me over on a sunday and he
makes a good sauce
really
it just could change the whole thing if
he comes over and the kid makes a mean
lasagne or spaghetti
i mean i'd like to punch his brother
right in the face
so i mean questions are you jealous of
that body seeing andrew cuomo's body
or chris chris would you ever want the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] got the
body that's why i'm a chris cuomo your
[ __ ] hero
for getting corona and crawling out of
your basement like anne frank
and walking into your multi-million
dollar hamptons house
you're so brave you are so brave
are you mad because he looks like miami
no i just was mine
he's a joint yeah let me ask you a
question yeah do you think when white
people walk into an indian restaurant
the waiter just shouts at the chef
chicken tikka masala
yo that's so funny i had an indian
friend that told me that was his
favorite meal and i
couldn't respect him ever again yeah i
was like you ain't [ __ ] out
of the white people had indian food you
know it's not indian you've never in
your life had indians never not once in
my life but
i would like to do it though i don't
bother really i just feel good
yeah i don't i hate being you're a
horrible ambassador i hate being that
guy i hate bridging gaps
you guys stay over there i'm good over
here
we eat but we will go to your shitty we
all eat if you want you can come but i
don't know i only need food that that
you could put on pizza you know what i
mean
i just want pizza and jana says giannis
coin me i only eat food that's on the
other side of a menu in a pizzeria yeah
that's all
tortellini's yeah you know like chicken
rolls he thinks we're in a restaurant
when he when we go to a pizza shop he
asks to see the menu that's how [ __ ]
trashy this kid is
rich he walks in he sits down he says
can i see your menu please and what are
the specials and the guy goes
what are you talking about the slices
are right there he says no i want it i
want the other side
i'm here for the pasta i'm here for the
special yeah that's that's the nice of
fine dining i take yoni to joe and
john's pizzeria and ridgewood yeah we
went to a [ __ ] 99-cent pizza store a
kid asked if he could have link winnie
with clamps
he's [ __ ] borrowed trash the indian
guy behind it
because i mean indian kids love making
pizza for 99 cents
they do because we love value yeah it's
yeah yeah so if you're out there yeah
and the
kamasutra is underrated i feel like
you're gonna you're about to
blow the [ __ ] up dude what is up with
kamasutra's like martial arts it's like
[ __ ] brazilian jiu jitsu [ __ ]
people
i mean open it up it's mad it's mad hard
the
positions are mad and possible yeah but
you gotta you gotta earn your belt
like they had nothing to do back then
except yoga they didn't have bills
right they were just doing stretches
they could do all this crazy it's the
martial arts of [ __ ] though
yeah really yeah does karma structure is
it is it fertility basically
it's very funny shirt is it oh i put an
r in there karma
yeah i keep it credit karma sutra
[Laughter]
keep it that way i like it for tilt like
like is it higher fertility too is that
what it's about orgasms
also there's a billion of us so probably
yeah right yeah i mean we out there
[ __ ] yeah
do who are some more people in india or
china who's who's number one
popularity number one that's yeah number
one they're out there
those are like that's like the [ __ ]
rafa nadal and roger federer of making
too many people
guys a lot of people ain't making
iphones in china you could go as a kid
we'll get rid of you if you're making
iphones we got a net there we'll throw
you back in the machine
right yeah do you hold hand with guys
when you go to india i don't yeah but i
seen it
yeah i seen it that's some [ __ ] manly
[ __ ] to do over there
are you allowed to wear socks in india
it's all open toe sandals all day every
day no
no if it's cold you're wearing socks in
the house it gets cold like that we just
don't have heat or insulation in the
house
typically so it's just cold as [ __ ]
because how obviously in india if we
walk down the street and we're not
holding hands they look at us like we're
gay
it's what it is yeah yeah i know i love
it
but that's the thing every culture is so
different i like it i want to go to
india how come you haven't had any
indians
i've never had indian food to i want to
go to india i legit want it
because he's lying 100
no the last thing this kid wants to do
i'd like to have a layover in india
hey let me tell you something when
you're on layover don't eat the food
don't drink the water
no i'm being dead serious once my
daughter is like maybe
11 12 years old i want to if i'm
hopefully enough financial people
are people poorer than puerto rico i
want yes i want to get her out of you
know because i took her you know
her mother her mother you know is puerto
rican from sunset park
and you know i mean she you never really
saw the world i mean the first time i
took her to preda manger she thought we
were in paris
you know
holly said that's it
is that the awful towel over there in
bay ridge i should know it's just pretty
manger on seventh day
because when she grew up in sunset park
was she looking at like two shiny cities
on a hill with park slope and bay ridge
yeah she was like one thing i'm gonna
get to one of them one day i'm going to
make it i'm telling you if i just keep
i'm going to find me somebody classy
i'm just going to go to those balls and
pretend to be interested in dave
matthews and then that's
it i got him that's right that's what it
is yeah so so
i want my daughter to you know because
all my whole family go out there so if i
would love to take them to india china
and do all that stuff
yeah you know in a few years uh so if i
go shopping for
your your family should i just go to
mandy's yeah just go to because if you
come in with an outfit for mandy's yeah
that's what it is about rainbow ain't
rainbows
i got you baby some uh sketchers
sneakers that light up is that gonna
work that's all it is that's what we
need yeah yeah
rainbow and queen helene hair gel yeah
do you think maybe we could help puerto
rico if we just sent them a bunch of
skechers to give the lights
yeah and you know what a lot of puerto
ricans voted trump that's just that's
the cold hard truth yeah
a lot of puerto ricans i know at least
in new york voted donny t
a lot of people are trying to play that
off like it's not a big deal but we're
talking about that's not true
no it's not i'm telling you i think i
well not a lot definitely majority voter
binding but i would say a higher
percentage
growing percentage puerto ricans more
more more people voted for trump more
puerto ricans vote for trump this this
time than last time
every group we're talking like from like
five percent yeah saying saying
yeah i don't know because hispanic is
37. why trump won florida is because in
miami-dade latinos
cubans flipped over to trump
conservative kids cubans would vote for
[ __ ] yeah
if you got a business they'll vote for
you yeah that's the thing as soon as you
say the word socialism they just
they're traumatized by cash drugs of
course which i understand
yeah you can't [ __ ] split a check
with a cuban you ever try to sit down
and say hey we should all just split
this they're like [ __ ] you you had six
fries
i had five i come from a communist
country i'm paying for mine you pay for
yours and they just
pull a gun out of you and say get away
from me you call me bastard yeah
these are don't touch my empanadas yeah
don't touch my [ __ ] traumatized
all right yeah yeah so so i mean you
know
to each their own that's what i'm about
but but whatever you want to do
the numbers went up though for trump for
trump i think it what is it if we google
it it's like
the black everybody went up except white
people black went to like eight
white men more black people voted for
trump than any republican
since like they since nixon or some
since they fought why is that why did
you vote for
us trump i didn't vote just give us some
insight on tesla
yeah if you got money you're going team
how funny was that when 50 cent finally
saw what the tax was going to be if you
made 400 and over he was like
that's what flipped all's vote was he
was going to vote for biden and then he
saw what 50 cents who he did he said i'm
not going to
think are liberal for the gram and then
in private oh my god
[ __ ] chances come on i'm trying to
tell you guys
fiscally conservative yeah you want to
pretend because all the people that buy
your [ __ ]
would benefit the most if bernie comes
into power so on the gram you say we
need this but then you get your
accountant's office and you're like how
do we hide all this [ __ ] money from
the government guys if i hired edward
snowden to get into sean king's laptop i
bet she voted trump
because he makes money
you